et je vous le dis il ya quelques
instants il ya une neuvième épisode du
chocolat gates vous n'étiez pas au
courant alors ton modalités joe lally
j'avais même pas tous leurs tirs
[Musique]
regardez un verdict vous qu'en d'autres
temps ils sont retrouvés une dentellière
aux reflets chocolat
[Applaudissements]
non
je reprenais leno
[Applaudissements]
il est magnifique attendu mes frères le
chocolat guèye les bacs
ça faisait sont vidés mais quand tu as
eu des soins y avait un vent de force 5
et les chargés de mal ces intrus go est
ce qu'on peut en voir
j'aimerais juste qu'on revoie le moment
où jeudi isabelle morini bosc et après
on va revoir ce qu'elle a pris mais
juste avant quand je lui dit isabelle
est ce que tu peux dire ce qu on a calé
ce moment c'est là que ça s'est joué
c'est à ce moment là mais on constate
quand même que vous avez de nous tous
choisi d'essayer de sauver isabelle
samedi répondu isabelle raynaud dans un
cerveau dont vous avez trois chouchous
non pas du tout ça va tourner il a
jamais été sauvés même antienne non plus
fellini benjamin et je tiens à préciser
que j'étais pas au courant que moi aussi
je voulais rester à la dictée à ce qu'il
était au courant est en cours et les
autres listes de courant et non à son
piper hagen des convois sûr que j'aurais
convoi
[Rires]
elle arrive enfin l'amf on est tous
attendent édité mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi les rester mais c'est la grande
question que je vous demande où pointe
est elle restée voilà